so we begin with breaking news out of
Pakistan and an attack on the stock
exchange in Karachi gunmen tried to
storm the building just over an hour ago
a grenade was thrown as the men entered
the compound security forces were
quickly on the scene and police say the
attack is over several people have been
killed let's get the latest from c'mon
Haider our correspondent in Islamabad
what more details can you tell us about
this attack Kemal what we know so far
four attackers stormed the Karachi Stock
Exchange building this has a very large
the security fencing around the
perimeter they loved a grenade and tried
to enter the compound however there was
stiff resistance from the guards at the
Karachi Stock Exchange and during that
time the law-enforcement agencies also
were able to deploy to the area a
gunfight ensued in which all four
attackers were killed one policeman also
killed and four of the guards who
resisted that attack kill it is
interesting to note that I've spoken to
somebody in the stock exchange who told
me that while the attack was still
underway business was as usual as per
normal
continued inside the trading continued
and after the attack also the stock
markets in fact showing a bit of a high
as well so indeed a message that the
work cannot be disrupted here despite
the fact that this could have been a
very serious attack given the fact that
a large number of grenades ammunition
assault rifles have been recovered from
those that were killed in the attack
today so the situation under control now
Kemal
who could be behind this attack there's
been no claim of responsibility yet but
who would want to target this
institution and why
well first of all it appears that this
for the pre-planned attack because we
also know that they had brought in dry
rations they would have tried to get
inside the stock exchange to cause as
much mayhem as possible so far the
number of attacks that have taken place
in Karachi have been traced back to the
Tanika Taliban Pakistan and also Baloo's